في بريطانيا يترك الاطباء الشباب من
الخريجين الجدد وظائفهم الثابته للعمل على
تيك توك ومضاعفه اجورهم وهي ازمه في وقت
تواجه الخدمات الصحيه في البلاد نقصا في
العماله واضرابات من اجل تحسين الظروف
مؤثرون رعايه الصحيه او كما يطلق عليهم في
الاعلام الغربي مدفلونزا هي ظاهره موجوده
منذ سنوات لكن ارتفعت كثيرا مع انتشار
الوباء والاغلاق المنزلي وتيك توك يرحب
بها اكثر من اي منصه اخرى في منطقه هنا
هناك الكثير جدا من تلك الحسابات وملايين
المتابعين لها ومن ان هناك العديد من
الاطباء الموثوقين الذين يرفعون الوعي حول
عادات خاطئه على حساباتهم او بتحضون خرافه
متداوله الا ان من الصعب كشف ما اذا كانت
طبيب طبيبا حقا المحتلا يقدم معلومات
المضلله ويسعى لزياده متابعين
[موسيقى]
فين بعدهم بوثق في بعضهم لا في بعد ما
بيطلعوا خداعين بيكذبوا علينا كثير وخصوصا
يعني هذا الشيء ما بصير بقدي الى شغلات
يعني لا تثق فيهم تروح تجرب
مفعول اكثر الموضوع
يعني نتاكد منه اكتر هسه بالنسبه
للمستحضرات لا لانه مستحضرات في اشياء
اثار جانبيه ممكن تاثر على مريض عنده مرض
معين غير المرض اللي هو بده ياخذ لاجل
الدواء يكون عنده ضغط او سكر او شيء فلازم
مراجعه طبيب او صيدلاني بنفس الوقت
يعني في دكاتره لهم اسمهم في السوق والناس
تعرفهم في دكاتره الناس ما بتعرفهم فجاه
مشهورين وعندهم كثير ما بنعرف كيف صارت
هاي الشغله يمكن دافعين
وبمناسبه هاي البروشورات وبالنهايه نكتشف
انه هذا الدكتور مش لا يصلح انه يكون
دكتور خيانه يحكي
الذي يدفع دكتور مثلك او طبيب مثلك للتوجه
من العيادات والمستشفيات الى منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي
كم موضوع انه نار الطبيب في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي امر بصراحه خلينا نقول غير
مقلوب
كانت وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هي احمد
طريقه لاصال المعلومه والوعي بالاضافه الى
التلفزيون الى المتابعين همم
انتاج الفراوله ولله الحمد
العديد من الاطباء انه بدا يكون قاعد
جماعيه
ههه
100%
بشكل كبير لان هذه التطبيقات نفسها وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي نفسها همم بدات تدعم
الاطباء اللي اصلا دخل فقط
يعني تجذب الناس والاطباء اللي كانوا اصلا
فقط داخلين عشان يوقعوا الناس وبجهه اخرى
الاطباء نفسهم كمان اكتشفوا انه انه ليش
لا طالما هو في دخل اضافي
هل صحيح وهل فعلا انه دخلك على تيك توك
اكثر من دخلك كطبيب في عياده
بصراحه ولكن السوشيال ميديا نقول بشكل عام
اا نعم نعم
لانه همم
لو لو رزق بقى لقينا فيه
ويبارك لنا كمان
[موسيقى]